[Musique]
ce mercredi 22 février le cnfpt a
organisé un colloque dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source sur le rôle des
collectivités en matière de prévention
de la radicalisation une journée de
sensibilisation à destination des
acteurs territoriaux que sont les élus
cadres et agents de terrain susceptible
d'être confronté à ce genre de situation
dans leur quotidien professionnel
il était nécessaire non seulement veut
former les acteurs de terrain mais
également de sensibiliser le management
1 les cadres et également les élus afin
qu'ils puissent accompagner et soutenir
mettre en place des protocoles inter on
sert des collectivités territoriales au
même titre que les autres régions de
france la réunion est touchée par le
phénomène de radicalisation des jeunes
il est donc important d'appréhender le
phénomène comprendre le processus de
radicalisation et s'informer sur le
dispositif national de prévention mises
en place on leur apprend déjà défini à
la radicalisation parce que ça attaquait
très utilisé par les médias mais très
souvent il est peu défini montré par
exemple que il ya de la radicalisation
aujourd'hui dans l'islam mais bien
toutes les religions dans tous les
systèmes politiques et montrer un petit
peu les ressorts de ce phénomène de
radicalisation notamment sur
sur les facteurs qui favorisent l'essor
de ce phénomène
une convention de partenariat a ensuite
été signé entre la préfecture la région
le département et l'association des
maires du département de la réunion afin
de lutter contre la radicalisation
aujourd'hui l'état avec les politiques
locales le département la région le
soutien des maires de la réunion décide
d'être ensemble de former le personnel
d'aider les associations
en clair d'avoir un acte citoyen qui
nous fait prévenir des formes de
radicalisation qui nous fait tenter de
garder ici ce vivre ensemble qui nous
est si cher il faut pouvoir défendre nos
valeurs pouvoir faire en sorte des
poumons interviennent que tous ceux qui
sont concernés
état collectivités associations puissent
agir ensemble pour prévenir de tels
phénomènes
la formation des acteurs sur le
phénomène de radicalisation constitue le
premier enjeu de l'action préventive
[Musique]